This video is sponsored by hymns
up
wisecrack.
Jared,
again,
we saw your request.
So today we're putting the crazy hat
back on to dive into the philosophy of
grant Morrison.
Writer of such a claimed works as also
our superman flex men,
tallow and multiversity like Alan Moore.
Greg Morrison was part of the British
invasion that revolutionized comics in
the 80s and also like more,
he's a self proclaimed magician with an
affinity for psychotropic drugs.
To me it just comes in a very simple
equation is that wife plus significance
equals magic.
But there are major differences between
them beyond their obvious discrepancy in
haircut philosophy,
as insane as more seems Morrison,
Mike be even crazier.
Wow.
He wrote some fictional girlfriends for
a fictional version of himself in the
invisibles and then later claimed that
they appeared in real life.
So as a result of this,
I just split up with my girlfriend and a
silky.
I want a new one.
Want it to look exactly like this,
check in the karmic cause she's cool.
So I did,
I said to him a monthly they oh tons up.
Then another one.
And when he wrote about this fictional
grant,
morrison being attacked by bacterial,
God's a demonic attack and or staph
infection brought real life grant
morrison to death's doorstep
a that if a,
if a pea coat to through the situation
where he's been taught to what his lungs
had bust and they've just been held in
captivity and subject until these awful
things,
the months late and I'm in hospital,
two bus,
lungs dying of blood poisoning and
facing exactly the same shamonic trial,
put my character through
Ben Christ appeared to him after which
he was healed and gain the superpower to
cure cancer in cats.
But all of that pales in comparison to
his experience in Katmandu.
It'd been abducted by aliens and count
mine in 1994
where he was abducted by rippling
dripping blobs of pure holographic
metamaterial angels and brought to a
mega medium in which entire universes
are suspended and shown the nature of
reality.
Allegedly it was like a Burrito of
religious revelation and alien abduction
all rolled into one.
Whether he actually ascended to a
heavenly hyperspace or was just tripping
balls is beside the point.
There's a surprising amount of
sober-minded philosophy and physics that
seem to agree with certain aspects of
Morrison's Katmandu experience,
including why he believes that the
universe is essentially just a giant
comic book and how he's the midwife to
an incredible future wherein we become
God.
Welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of grant Morrison spoilers
ahead and if you want to dive even
deeper into the mind of this mad genius,
join us over@wisecrackplus.com
for an hour long podcast interview with
the creators of this video.
To be clear,
Morrison is not suggesting we could ever
become the capital g God described in
the Bible,
Torah or the Quran.
You know,
a single almighty creator of all things.
When comic writers use the Word God,
it's more often with a lowercase g like
the north stady turned marvel hero,
thor or other immensely powerful beings
with this logic morrison regards of the
Justice League as the Pantheon of
American mythology and deliberately
structured his roster in Jla two
parallel there,
Olympian counterparts.
Now we want to be very specific in
saying that he doesn't merely mean
humans will become super power post
humans one day.
He means something much more.
It's Captain Adam who,
uh,
inspired Moore's doctor Manhattan that
gives us our first hint as to what
Morrison means by God.
Both captain Adam and doctor Manhattan
achieved God's status because of their
view of time.
They experience every event in their
lives simultaneously.
It's not that they have perfect recall
of the past and total knowledge of the
future for them.
There is no pastor future.
Instead,
every single moment is equally,
eternally real.
Picture a film reel as it rolls forward
at 24 frames per second.
The light projects one image on the
screen at any given moment.
In this analogy,
the screen is reality and only that
single frame is real,
uh,
frame pops into existence as the
projector illuminates it and pops out of
existence.
As we move on to the next frame,
this is what philosopher jme mctaggart
calls the theory of time.
It's how we as humans perceive time
mactaggarts be theory.
On the other hand is that events do not
have objective tents.
So imagine if we were to eliminate each
frame of the film reel all at once so
that we could simultaneously gaze upon
every single moment in the movie.
The main school of thought among be
theorists is eternalism,
which claims every moment in time is
eternal from the big bang to the heat
death of the universe.
Nothing ever pops in or out of
existence,
rather events exist alongside one
another.
The shattering of this illusion is a
frequent trope and morrison's writings
in the invisibles Lord Fanny's
initiation into magic is accomplished at
the age of 11 when the remainder of fan,
he's life getting raped and beaten and
Rio drugged out in a drag club in
London,
even eventually dying is experienced as
if it already happened.
The Aztec Goddess Basil Tiotto reveals
to Fanny.
Time is not a river.
Time is more like a bubble,
but is to a bubble.
What a bubble is to a circle drawn on
the ground.
So Morrison philosophizes about the
nature of time in his stories.
Cool,
right?
Well,
he takes it further.
Way further to Morrison.
A slightly more literal version of this
be theory of time lies in the very
medium of the comic book on any given
page.
If you were to ask the heroes,
they tell us that page and that panel
was the present moment so far as they
could tell,
but as the reader we see that all the
panels,
all the pages,
all the printed issues are all equally.
Now their time is an illusion,
but one,
two,
which we're not subjected.
Even the two dimensional flat piece of
paper on which comics are drawn may be
an apt analog for the structure of space
time per morrison.
Our universe may even all be a hologram
projected onto a flat mega membrane
which is in turn embedded along with
many others like it within a higher
dimensional space.
He's referring in his own way to the
holographic principle per Stephen
Hawking.
Information associated with all
phenomenon in the three dimensional
world can be stored on a two dimensional
boundary,
like a holographic image.
In a certain sense,
the world would be two dimensional like
the pages of a comic book.
So far.
Everything Morrison said seems like a
reasonable conclusion to draw from
mainstream theoretical physics and if
all he had to say was that just as a
film reel is a fitting analogy for eight
theory.
So two is a comic book and Apt Analogy
for the b theory of time,
his contribution would be entirely
warranted,
but then the cat man to experience went
down and things got weird.
Now,
although his more out,
their ideas don't necessarily hold up to
scientific scrutiny,
they're still worth exploring because
they take comic books and superheroes
stories and turn them into a compelling
worldview whether warranted or not.
Many look to figures like superman and
captain America for moral inspiration.
Morrison offers some justification for
emulating fictional heroes,
treating them as gods and even go so far
as to say that the idea of superman is
every bit as real as the idea of God and
suggest that we are even more super,
even more godlike.
It's for this reason that Morrison
depicts philosopher Giovanni Pico de la
mere and Dola in the pages of all star
Superman delivering his famous oration
on the dignity of man.
As he later said in his autobiography,
Pecos Oratoria is without a doubt urging
us to go far beyond the human into the
realm of angels and Gods.
It asks us to accept the superhuman as
an undeniable fact of our nature and the
goal of our future evolution as a
people.
Although his metaphors are biblical,
suggesting Cherubs and Sarah F's and
thrones as our role models and
intermediaries on the road to God or
cosmic consciousness,
we can just as easily call them
superheroes.
So what happened at Kathmandu that made
Morrison believe that the universe
really is a comic book and that humanity
really is a superhero?
Well,
he claims to have stepped outside the
multiverse and seeing reality from the
outside,
the universe,
the entire space time continuum from big
bang to heat death,
no less was not a linear stream of
events with beginning,
middle and end.
That was only how it felt from the
inside.
All Life on earth was one thing,
a single weird anemone like mega hydro
with its single celled and mortal route
in precambrian tides,
a slowly complexifying,
increasingly self aware super organism.
It was all of us all life as seen from
the perspective of a higher dimension,
whereas eternalism his content to
conclude that spacetime is a timeless
four dimensional object.
Morrison goes beyond eternal wisdom by
claiming that by the same principle
every human being is actually a mere
sell in a single super organism that is
humanity.
And therefore if each one of us is part
of a larger hole,
then all truism and beneficence and
charity are in our own self interest.
The simplistic divide of right and wrong
and good and evil and superhero comics
suddenly seems less silly because our
morals aren't arbitrary social
constructs.
They're the genetic programming
instructing this super organism not to
destroy itself.
Indeed,
this view as a basis for ethics is the
very conclusion lex luthor reaches when
he gains Superman's powers and upon
seeing with his super senses all of the
fundamental forces and how they're
interconnected,
he begins to weep.
This is how he sees all the time every
day like it's all just us in here
together and we're all we've got,
okay,
so if humanity as a whole is like a
superhero comic book,
we should therefore behave like these
costume do gooders.
It's a compelling case,
but if you think that's weird,
he also saw fifth dimensional aliens or
what he called mercurial,
hyper sprites,
five dimensional intelligence as could
as a condition of their geometrically
elevated position.
Get into our skulls quite easily and we
could expect their voices to come from
inside.
They in turn could hear our thoughts as
easily as we can read Batman's private
inner monologues on a two d page.
This is illustrated in multiversity,
Pax Americana Number One,
while reading a comic book Captain Adam
uses to two scientists.
The stories linear,
but I can flip through the pages in any
order,
any direction forward in time.
To the conclusion,
back to the opening scene,
the characters remained unaware of my
scrutiny,
but their thoughts are transparent,
weightless and little clouds.
This is how a two dimensional continuum
looks to you.
Then staring straight ahead.
He says,
imagine how your three d world appears
to me.
Adam's fourth wall break brings us to
another major theme in Morrison's Works
Meta fiction Alec,
which is the exploration of the
relationship between the fiction itself
with the real world of the writer and
reader Morrison first wrestled with
[inaudible] in the final issue of his
run on animal man in which he dawned
what he calls a fiction suit.
He inserts himself into the comic itself
to interact with the character he notes.
I explained to my character how the
people who wrote his life needed drama
and shock and violence to make his story
interesting.
The implication was that our own lives
may be written to entertain or to
instruct an audience in a perpendicular
direction.
We could never point to interacting with
us in ways we could scarcely understand,
but that could be divided in the
relationship of the comic world to the
world of the Creator and audience.
This is the crux that connects
Morrison's metta fiction to his musings
on spacetime.
If comic books reflect the nature of our
universe,
can we say that the physical comic like
universe reflects the nature of some
higher reality?
Who are our cosmic comic creators who
writes the plotlines of history,
pencils,
the particle interactions,
letters,
the thought balloons of intelligent
minds?
Morrison's answer is the fifth
dimensional aliens that we cannot grasp
with our feeble three dimensional mines,
but he admits the particulars are less
important than the implications that
follow from there being intelligent
designers.
If the analogy of our universe being
like a comic book extends so far as to
suggest that it has something like a
writer,
then the mere fact that it is a written
work implies a purposefulness to our
existence.
Now,
of course,
being created doesn't necessarily in
part dignity,
we might be like morrisons animal man
with all our suffering for no greater
purpose can to provide drama in a piece
of cheap entertainment.
We might be made by a hack.
Our whole purpose might be to pass
butter,
but contra his younger self.
When writing animal man,
the more mature Morrison became more
optimistic in flex men,
tallow man of muscle mystery.
Morrison once again used [inaudible] as
a means of exploring questions about our
own purpose.
Just as Morrison sees,
reality is having a three tiered
structure with his fifth dimensional
emcee at the top,
the two d comic book characters at the
bottom and us in the middle.
So two is the story of flexpen tallow
set across three levels of reality.
There's the cartoon world of Flex
Metallo.
The realistic world of Flexes Writer
Wall is sage and Avatar,
Morrison himself,
and yet a higher reality inhabited by
superheroes more real than they're
writers or the fifth dimensional aliens.
In the story,
it's revealed that superheroes,
instead of being merely a product of the
imagination of writers like wally,
were in fact the beings that created
wally's entire world after which they
retreated in the imagination,
seeding our culture with superhero
stories in anticipation of the day that
mere mortals are ready to become like
them.
As a result,
humanity only needs to resolve their
uncertainty about whether superheros are
real or not,
and decide to believe them into
existence here,
Morrison to suggesting a much more
dignified purpose to our existence.
We're meant to discover our fundamental
purpose in the pages of comic books and
to believe into existence.
The idea of the superman to incarnate
him in ourselves for Morrison,
the medium of comics and the plot
structure of superhero stories are so
closely connected in our culture because
both are parts of the same pattern that
explained everything else in existence.
In recognizing this pattern,
Morrison writes his own autobiography,
Super Gods in the style and structure of
an archetypical superhero story,
including a secret origin in Glasgow,
the call to adventure,
a top Katmandu and a death and rebirth
in which he brings the hidden knowledge
he gained on his hero's journey to the
comics community,
and while that hidden knowledge is
parsed out in piecemeal and his comics
writing,
it's in super gods where he's most
explicit about just what makes humankind
itself a Super God.
Already we can see humankind is having
all the attributes of comic book
superheroes or even Pagan Gods.
Whereas mercury carried messages at the
speed of thought to the Roman gods.
We have instantaneous interconnectivity
via the internet,
whereas heme dolls all seeing I could
spy everywhere in all nine realms are
satellites can zoom in on any spot on
earth like superman.
We flown faster than a speeding bullet.
Humanity when viewed as a whole is
already a super God insofar as there is
no future frames of the film reel
popping into existence.
We are not becoming the Super God.
We already always are.
This epic of human history is merely its
secret origin story as to how it gets
it's superhuman powers,
but all of its ongoing adventures and
never ending battles to come are all
already written,
published,
printed,
and on the shelves of some higher
dimensional comic shop.
If mankind is this super organism with
all these stupendous powers who supposed
to act according to the simple morality
of a superhero whose whole history is
structured like a superhero story and
who's living in a cosmos that's
constructed like a comic book,
then Morrison's obvious conclusion is
this.
Mankind's purpose is to be a superhero.
It's for this reason that Morrison calls
the Sun God from Smallville,
our greatest ever idea as the human
species.
Not because superman was the prototype
on which all other superheroes would be
based,
but because he is the template for which
these Super God,
if humanity must become all powerful and
all good all at the same time.
This is the summation of Morrison's
philosophy articulated Bestbuy Jarell to
his one and only son regarding the
essential truth about man and superman
and not the mankind within the comics,
but the mankind reading comics.
You have given them an ideal to aspire
to embodied their highest aspirations.
They will race and stumble and fall and
crawl and curse and finally they will
join you in the Sun Palau,
but hey,
whether or not we accomplish wonders,
the doctors who work with hymns have
come pretty close.
Hims has created a personalized and
private online store for men to get
recommendations from real doctors for
FDA approved prescription and
nonprescription products without leaving
home.
What kind of products you ask?
Well,
look guys,
some things are difficult to discuss
with a doctor.
Hair loss affects two out of every three
men by age 35 and thanks to science
baldness can now be optional.
Hims offers medical grade solutions to
help treat hair loss.
Hims is offering wisecrack viewers a
full month trial of their complete hair
kit up to a $67 value for just five
bucks while supplies last.
So head over to [inaudible] dot com
slash wise crack or click the link below
to get your discount today.
And big thanks to hymns for sponsoring
this video and to grant Morrison for
being even crazier than Alan Moore
piece.
Yeah.